well it was a movie called american dog
that's been worked on for for a while of
course john lasseter came in and took
over uh disney animation and we all we
all senses the beginning of something
and so everybody was giving everything
they had and i think when we when we
first showed the story and people said
okay we've got got something here we've
got a good solid story and then uh that
fit into enthusiasm and other
departments and as each department kind
of took on this philosophy of over
delivering the next department downline
would say oh well we have to do it too
and so people would kind of constantly
be kind of raising their game all the
way uh along the line and it kept the
the studio uh alive and vital through
this very tough production period
because we did this in i think two years
and it's short from for cg yeah it's
true film and uh and we did ask a lot of
people and we we never backed off on
what the quality that we wanted from the
film but the devotion of the crew of
those 450 people and their families
that's that really speaks to how much
they care about this movie and how proud
they can be of it yeah there was there
on one day i had a lighter come to me
and said he'd seen some incredible
animation really nice piece and really
nice acting some acting choices an actor
that an animator had made and he said
well now it's really up to me i mean i
have to serve that animation i have to
give him great lighting and that same
day an animator came to me and said you
know i saw one of my scenes lit and it
was so awesome and really motivated him
to want to you know improve his
animation and and there is this cyclical
thing that happens you know when you
start to when one department starts to
raise their game the other departments
start to be really inspired by that and
that was the feeling that was happening
over the course of making both is that
that that we were really there was the
potential here to make something that we
could all be really proud of at the end
of the day the idea i've been at the
studio for for a while there was a it
was an idea that everybody
got and responded to when they heard the
title kung fu panda which put two
sort of opposites together kung fu
something that was very hardcore and
very martial required a lot of athletic
ability and self-discipline and then
pandas kind of the total opposite of
that the most cuddly soft really pearly
snoozy animals you can you could imagine
and you put the two things together and
people would laugh and go i wonder what
that story would be um but finding that
idea hadn't happened i mean it was it
was it kind of mocked martial arts
movies and it had a lot of contemporary
references a lot of pop culture
references and pop songs and things and
it was like all right what should this
movie be let's let's let's honor the
source material which is you know
martial arts movies let's not mock them
let's try and make a martial arts movie
albeit a funny one with with with
animals and let's try and commit to that
and take it seriously and make it
beautiful and fill it with emotion and
just do it right and
that became the new journey that we
embarked on we sort of looked to jack
black
for inspiration and
uh look to tenacious d his band also
sort of as a you know the great fan boys
that you know dream of becoming
something greater believe that there's
something much greater than um than what
they appear to be in 94
year before toy story came out we
realized hey we may actually get to make
another movie this may not suck
and they may pay us money to do it again
because we were a one-time deal with
disney yeah and um
so we we said
wait a minute we're two years behind
development and so we said
we ran and got went to we got went to
had a lunch and we started throwing a
million ideas
and bug's life came out of that lunch
but the one of the other sort of
little ideas that was half baked was
wouldn't it be cool to do a sci-fi
picture
and i think it was pete that said you
know
what if it was like this little trash
compacting robot that just sort of kept
doing its job he had no idea even even
after everybody left
that
it was he could stop he could just keep
but he keeps going and i said i would
see a whole movie like that says totally
and then the next sentence was nobody
would ever let us make a movie like that
we hadn't even proven we could do toy
story you know we were still not out of
the woods so we literally just put it up
on the shelf and then i always have
soundtrack music playing and sometimes
something sparks me and i just loop it
forever i think it was for all the geeks
jerry goldsmith's star trek main theme
it started to become clear to me that it
it had to be a love story and then i
found myself for the next week begging
for more rewrite time
but i was really writing this
and i
told myself that that was okay because
it's productive procrastination
this is for a film we'll need in the
future
so how can this be bad